y'avait des médias qui était en mode
mais en millions mais c'est positif à ça
ils prennent pas forcément ce domaine au
sérieux ils voient pas l'impact que ça
ils ne comprennent pas trop pourquoi des
gens aiment bien regarder d'autres
personnes jouer à des jeux vidéo le
streaming c'est simple en fait c'est
quelqu'un qui est en train de jouer à un
jeu vidéo et les autres qu'il le regarde
il ya des gens qui explique des choses
des gens qui jouent bien au jeu vidéo
des gens qui font une sorte de spectacle
en mode humour
donc on peut regarder pour plusieurs
raisons à streamer de jeux vidéo mais en
général c'est surtout pour passer un bon
moment où apprendre des choses c'était
très surprenant de récolter autant
d'argent en si peu de temps et quand on
a passé la barre du million moi j'avoue
j'ai eu une petite larmichette parce que
je trouve que c'est beau en fait les
gens sont au rendez-vous nous font
confiance tous et streamer qui se sont
réunis pour la bonne cause c'était hyper
émouvant et j'avais rarement eu une
émotion comme ça c'était très fort vous
savez moins de 30 ans et vous venez de
créer un événement caritatif vient de
récolter 1 million d'euros comment vous
sentez vous juste après we insist robin
1 ce monde est fabuleux le monde peut
être magnifique
[Musique]
je sais pas à quel point les médias se
rendent ou pas compte de l'impact que
par le jeu vidéo mais moi j'ai aussi
conscience du fait que c'est une
fracture générationnelle
c'est un petit temps a passé et en fait
le temps fera la sphère donc voilà il
faut juste être patient il faut juste
encourager les bonnes personnes à nous
aider et je pense qu'avec ça ça va venir
il y avait des médias qui était en mode
1 million mais c'est pas beau c'est
qu'il fasse ça déjà hier ils ont fait
500 milles la chance et ils prennent pas
forcément ce domaine au sérieux ils
voient pas l'impact que ça ils pensent
que c'est que des enfants de 12 ans qui
regarde ça et comprennent pas trop
pourquoi des gens aiment bien regarder
d'autres personnes jouer à des jeux
vidéo et c'est vrai que du coup alors
montré un peu ce contraste alors montré
que ben c'est pas que juste ça
c'est plutôt qu'il en est et puis
j'espère que certaines personnes nous
verrons les yeux les iron que c'est pas
juste des branleurs dans leur chambre du
jeu vidéo tout simplement
[Musique]
tu as regardé ma longueur d'onde que
j'en sais pas c'est que ça va mettre six
mois à l'e3 ou genre 2 1
[Musique]
et je suis pas très utile dans la vie de
tous les jours mais je crois que
vous et nous on a tous été à notre
manière un peu utile soukèye guèye a
réussi à faire ce kit vingtaine d'années
le trentenaire
c'était la honte d'être avoir un gamer
dire qu'on avait pas de vie qu'on
faisait rien quantité de déchets humains
à leur ferment leur gueule
l'ancien vous tous